leevon uh started with the white pieces
once again against a good friend tell us
about your approach to this one are you
satisfied with the
result well um I wanted just you know to
get a fighting game uh the result is
okay you know Fab is a strong player uh
but uh I don't like that I was uh you
know defending in instead of uh putting
pressure but I I think I I a couple of
things at some point and I got a bit
careless but uh generally uh I mean I
was calculating and I saw that uh the
game really didn't uh you know walk away
from me as to say you know so it was
always close to a draw as players
especially when we first start a
tournament we always try to gauge our
shape our form that we're in after the
first game how do you feel your shape in
this tournament
it's okay uh I think um you know I'm
normally a slow starter so uh I happened
to lose quite a lot in the first round
so I didn't lose it's it's already good
thing guys any questions just a quick
question uh uh leavon you played the
move Rook
C1 which uh as I understand it you
wanted to play for the move C2 C4 but
then after you traded on E5 right here
you took the the the bishop and after
that as you said you were more or less
required to defend the position why
didn't you follow it up with your idea
which was
C4 yeah well this was my original idea
but I wasn't really sure about long
Castle long castle Yeah Yeah because
after 95 Queen E5 yes Knight F3 yes
Queen H5 I didn't really like
Queen H5 so even in this position where
you've opened up a file you didn't like
this pin that was happening this you
know the G5
G4 might come too quick I got you what I
was worried about but there's there's
actually a move for white which I didn't
see instead of C take d uh White has
yeah Queen H5 white has Queen C2 which
is very very precise stopping G5 because
of Queen F5 and
maybe this is good for white I see yeah
just I I just wanted to ask why you
didn't follow up with what was obviously
your idea after Rook C1 with C4 uh Leon
I have a quick question Fabby was just
saying that his preparation for this
tournament was more resting because he
was playing a lot of tournaments um so
he needed to take a break and make sure
he is ready for the championship what
about you did you have a any special
preparation or I believe you also played
a number of tournaments so was resting
uh the main part of your preparation for
this
tournament um my main uh preparation as
always is spending time with my family
so and I succeeded in that and uh so I'm
ready for the tournament now because my
uh my in-laws are in town my daughter is
here you know what else can the man ask
for lot of support there exactly thank
you leavon and we've got a very exciting
game that's unraveling right as we speak
so we're going to get back to it
Christian guys